jean luc lemoine pas les 4theroad
[Applaudissements]
il est bon et les pires houle m
jean luc lemoine attendu comment annuler
4/3 vous savez que c'est une rubrique
que j'aime énormément
ça fait plaisir voilà j'espère que je ne
vais pas m'en prendre dans la gueule
cette semaine
si vous en faites pas non si ça fait
plaisir mais non mais je vous ai entendu
entendu chez philippe vandel
ah oui bonjour et vous disiez chaque
semaine pendant 20 minutes on prend
plein la gueule et jean luc lemoine même
s'il est à la hauteur sur une question
aurait fait pas attention le respect de
l'homme oui bien sûr de l'artiste
bonjour je m'appelle et jean-luc je
voudrais vous dire que l'année dernière
je ne regardais pas votre émission
mais cette année avec la nouvelle
formule je ne la regarde toujours pas
est-ce qui vous êtes content quand même
ma mère c'est jean-luc nous sommes très
contents enfin pas que vous regardiez
pas mais de la nouvelle formule et car
cette analyse tout le monde l'a remarqué
ses formes et la grameen voilà il ya eu
beaucoup de changements qui font la
différence
déjà ses rides et un autre homme plus
mature plus équilibré et plus beau oui
plus beau tout simplement dirait une pub
une ligne parfaite une nouvelle coupe de
cheveux qui lui permettrait de recevoir
des étrennes dans n'importe quelle
maison de retraite
tout a été pensé jusqu'au moindre détail
sont des images exclusives qui se sont
déroulés lundi pendant la pub et que
j'ai fait mais moi même
je n'ai pas ramassé
j'étais dans le déni
j'adore les femmes elles mêmes mais
c'est fait brosser le coupon que après
puisse faire merci au passage sera ya un
an qui m'a autorisé à la filmer sans
l'aide que peut nous rappeler ce que tu
fais dans la vie mais vous rigolez mais
c'est important les poils chez cyril sa
gamme 85% concorde
oui et cyril et un autre homme depuis
cette rentrée si vous êtes venus ici
pour m'enfoncer à moi j'attends que les
parieurs mais je vous le dis j'ai jugé à
ces problèmes j'ai plein d'amis sans
plus je faisais votre pub
bon bah les six noms mais depuis la
rentrée et ça va faire plaisir à rachid
a touché pas une bouche il fait
attention à son vocabulaire qu'une
grosse fierté en cette émission certains
prétendent et qui maltraitait ses
chroniqueurs maintenant pendant la pub
ni les bichonne comme là où il était
venu caresser les cheveux de valérie
bénaïm
ces dames et son soyeux
[Musique]
[Rires]
rechuter antennes oui gérard antenne ses
terres en tête jusqu'à présent au galbe
et l'iran chiite
rachid tu va relever les compteurs après
ça que le moteur est maintenant banni
dans tekken mais aulas malheureux à
l'entrée du plateau il ya un panneau
nothum inside met d'ailleurs en parlant
de pub
jean michel est revenu très affûté
niveau humour non mais c'est bien simple
on en est là je vais être sincère était
déjà impressionnant l'année dernière là
mais c'est devenu une machine et dès
qu'ils passaient du best-of direct alors
pour lui rendre hommage
une de ses meilleures de la semaine
dernière vous régis j'étais avec une
jeune fille cet été qui travaillent avec
moi qui venais du pérou elle m'a dit le
seul chanteur que je connais en france
ça c'est amir faut dire que c'est vrai
que la péruvienne on était là-bas je
joue un petit peu de foot de pompes
habito serge lama renom
et on a vraiment rigolé comme ça sur
cette zone
en fait lorsque je ne vous montrez là
c'est ça c'est ce que jean michel aurait
voulu voir c'est parce que je me disais
enfin voilà parce que voilà s'il peut
enchaîner au niveau du texte vont très
bien là non parce que j'allais voir si
on n'était pas en direct et qu'on
pouvait faire du montage ah oui
terminons n'ai pas pu dire que les
autres c'est si on était en différé on
aura l'air à briand comment toutes les
émissions mais non stérile et veut faire
des direct au plus malin que les autres
celui-là résultat qu'on soit michel que
des vannes voilà ce qui se passe en
réalité c'est pas la même fluidité ni la
même efficacité vous rejeté avec une
jeune fille cet été qui travaillent avec
moi qui venais du pérou elle m'a dit le
seul chanteur que je connais en france
ça c'est amir vous jure que c'est vrai
que la paix revienne en été
c'est un mytho serge lama non merci j'ai
fait pire oui c'est mieux i'm here on à
ce comité avons trouvé une chronique
l'important maintenant à quoi ça sert le
montage de télévision sinon je vois très
brillant michel qui a aussi fait une
très bonne rentrée grâce au live
musicaux qui ouvre désormais l'émission
alors vous allez voir soprano était venu
nous présenter à nouveau single c'était
mon précieux j'adore et époque ait pas
de confusion
il doit expliquer de quoi ça parlait
avant de chanter et gentille fille qu'il
a bien fait ta grâce à jean michel s'est
bien mis dans l'ambiance est arrivé
comme ça jean mi pour kiffer bessard de
quoi il parle de notre addiction
avec le téléphone
[Musique]
au ps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah qu'il est bon ce sera hollande jean
michel qui a fait une première semaine
tonitruante puisque a aussi présenté
c'est que de l'amour ce jeu remarquable
qui un soir dans les annales de ces vite
juste à côté de the cover une caisse
noire spécialistes mais une émission qui
changent d'animateurs trois fois en
trois jours
c'est comme un club de foot qui change
d'entraîneur toutes les semaines ça sent
jamais bon pas du tout c'était prévu
depuis le début on dit on va faire une
tournante
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je lance le jeu le premier jour après
avoir représenté le veut il ya eu vous
mais il ya eu jean michel ribes benjamin
ouais vous devriez pas confier des
émissions assure michel il est fragile
des responsabilités après il se la
raconte
résultat le lendemain pendant le live de
nazim il se prenait pour le producteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon phone avant sa main sans
commentaire très bien vous non plus
château dessus de la mêlée où tu es
nazim c'est génial ah oui c'est vrai le
titre fait un carton merci je souhaite
autant d'audience que benjamin vraiment
en plus bas est très aimé du public déjà
parce qu'il dit toujours la vérité comme
l'a alors que c'est que s'extasier
devant la tenue de caroline ithurbide si
elle part dans l'espace
je lui connais pas mal en super héros
dont je connais pas vu lever la séance
entre les deux mois je franchement je
web un jeu compliqué ajustements
justement je vais parler de toi dans les
nouveautés de la rentrée il ya aussi
bien évidemment des nouveaux
chroniqueurs dont pierre ménès qui a
tout de suite expliqué valérie benaïm
comment il fonctionnait
j'aimerais les enfants
sait-on
monsieur
hoyé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la première avait alors dans les
nouvelles en cui aussi évidemment kelly
ben je vais réveiller oui j'ai combien
de doigts il quatre saisons les
réveiller kelly dont je ne dirais pas de
mal parce que quand vous fait la moindre
remarque ce colis jean-michel grince
c'est très étonnant à regarder
merci kelly avec nous et je très content
très content content très content de ta
présence vraiment ait rempli c'est
vraiment et au début quand je t'avais vu
physiquement j'étais pas pour faire des
commentaires toutes les missions
[Applaudissements]
donc il est arrivé pour le plus grand
bonheur d'un gâteau proulx parce qu'avec
ses lunettes de bibliothécaire de films
érotiques un drapeau musicale cats
étaient tout jeunes et que donc dans
l'équipe
elle avait l'impression est auxiliaire
de vie pour personnes âgées là
maintenant elle est en fait une copine
de sa génération et ça a tout changé
on découvre la vraie agathe avec des
préoccupations et des conversations de
son âge
[Musique]
c'est à la salle
non ma femme que je déteste les gens
voient pas mérité
[Musique]
alors je me suis dit j'ai passé de
belles soit en hiver je n'en sais pas si
ça se fait avec et on sait jamais où on
sait on sait qu'il peut répondre tout de
suite sa main au panier non y'a aucun
moyen dans les tirs vendredi
moi je sais pourquoi pourquoi as tu es
un peu lourd
moi je suis très léger avec kelly voilà
les raisons de presque tourner des
transports avec maxime est très mignon
je vais déposer d'aller dîner dès ce
soir
non et dès ce soir là bas lui dire non
et avec machine gun histoire non mais
[Applaudissements]
vous allez aller dîner en forme ce soir
et bien sûr on fera le brief demain bien
sûr je raconterai surmené vitaux tués
franchement non mais vraiment mais
vraiment alors en revanche c'est pas bon
gentlemen je fais toujours les dianes
pas que je suis gamin je partage
aujourd'hui alors je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez mais le jour de la rentrée
quand vous allez au premier la classe
vous redoutez redouter une seule chose
vous asseoir à côté du bad boy
celui qui toute l'année va copier sur
vous vous piquer vos gommes passé ce qui
est arrivé à maxime guinea la semaine
dernière je veux que ça va vous rappeler
la petite école mais j'ai trouvé ça
il refuse pas mais enfin la cuisse mais
il faut quand même un peu peur faut dire
que jean michel et maxime c'est par la
grosse entente
c'est pas qu'il sème pas c'est juste
qu'ils se comprennent pas surtout quand
maxime fait de l'humour je paye un
format
normal c'est
un bo5
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci isabelle louis masson n'est pas ce
que tu dit un truc comme ça pas lui non
plus il est avec toi il est pas ça pour
ça que vous n'avez pas compris non plus
j'ai faits de violence parfois à oui ça
m'arrive street évalue vous à l'équipe
et je sois un peu de bon sens alors tant
qu'on est dans les blagues un petit
cadeau offert par le patron en personne
si regardez bien jusqu'au bout vous
noterez que pendant l'été syrie s'est
acheté un nouveau rire
[Musique]
tu sais mike brant quelle est la
dernière chanson qui l'a écoutée fais
comme l'oiseau camp nou du doublage
il est bon pourquoi tout à fait passer
s'il ne s'est pas jetée career acheter
trop 4-1 celui ci qui se situe entre la
joie et la peine aux dauphins les
échanges
alors bien sûr vous allez me demander
pourquoi certains bâtard qui dépasse
clairement ils sont vingt mois il dit
était un tarbes à eybens personne ne
fait de blagues faut que je vous avoue
un secret c'est l'effet une vanne qui
n'assume pas il se persuade que
quelqu'un pauvre pense que oui alors que
pas du tout
là c'était pendant le magnéto sur raquel
garrido à bas coût low cost de thierry
ardisson
dix jours qu'ils veulent le troisième
production
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas ça par coeur non me croire
mais quand excuses et quand bien même je
termine que c'est pas un monstre il
raquel garrido non plus c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était super consulter mais c'est vrai
qu'elle en plus la bise ou raquel ouais
bah non pourquoi je la connais pas bon
bah voilà
bon allez pour finir le top gène ans
vous savez cette petite compilation de
tous les moments étranges et pas
toujours explicables de tpm b
[Musique]
ou locaux jean remise du rapport
pakistan pour le cochon rapport avec
mention qui gît les absences sidérant il
est jamais content de partir du moment
où une fois manu ces messieurs sont
faibles 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]